[Musique]
bonjour bonjour excusez-moi de vous
déranger dans votre course si je vous
dis Hélène Boucher vous me répondez quoi
collège de chartre et aviatrice je ne
connais pas h boucher je connais le
collège hé boucher c'est qui c'est c'est
un collège un lycée non une aviatrice
très
connueir vous connaissez Hélène Boucher
oui c'est c'est une grande pilote
c'était bah
elle a emmené bah pour les femmes tout
en avavant
[Musique]
quoi bonjour à toutes et tous et
bienvenue à chartre rue Hélène Boucher
une rue bien connue de ses habitants et
habitantes certainement mieux d'ailleurs
que l'illustre aviatrice parce parce
être une femme aviatrice à cette époque
inimaginable en 1930 Hélène Boucher a 22
ans elle passe son baptême de l'air et
décide de faire de l'aviation sa
vie en 1933 elle enchaîne les
performances en battant notamment le
record du monde d'altitude la même année
elle se lance dans la voltige et devient
rapidement l'une des plus grandes
acrobates aérienne au monde Hélène
Boucher féministe engagée milite
activement en faveur du droit de vote
pour les femmes en 1934 elle emporte le
titre de championne du monde de vitesse
toute catégorie et cette même année se
tu à seulement 26
[Musique]
ans et maintenant me voilà sur le
Parville de la cathédrale de chartre
nous allons aller à la rencontre de
Catherine monouri grande championne
françise de voltige aérienne digne
héritière d'Hélène boucher et qui va
partager avec nous l'influence qu'a eu
Hélène Boucher sur sa
passion bonjour Catherine bonjour Céline
alors que représente pour vous Hélène
Boucher elle fait vraiment partie de ces
icônes qui m'ont fait rêver et qui m'ont
donné envie de devenir comme elle en
plus elle elle a disparu tôt donc elle
est elle est une espèce d' Dole quelque
chose de presque impossible à atteindre
mais qui donne envie de marcher dans ses
pas et qu'est-ce qui vous anime tant
dans l'idée de voler de voltiger depuis
toujours les humains ont rêvé de voler
et je partage avec Hélène Boucher une
sorte de révélation le jour de mon
bapthême aérien la première fois que
j'ai volé c'était clair je n'avais que 8
ans mais je savais que mon destin venait
de se décider là et elle il lui est
arrivé la même chose un peu plus âgée
elle devait avoir dans les 20 ans et
bien à ce moment-là elle est sortie très
sérieuse en disant
c'est ça mais j'ai trouvé je vais voler
et quel regard vous posez sur la place
des femmes dans la voltige et plus
largement l'aviation les femmes ont
toujours volé dès le début elles sont là
on les a barré à partir de la guerre où
on trouvait que c'était mieux qu'ell
soit infirmière et on les a pas laissé
combattre mais maintenant toutes les
portes sont ouvertes il faut juste ne
plus y penser et si vous aviez quelques
mots adressés à à des jeunes femmes
d'aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous leur
diriez il crois qu'il faut jamais
laisser d'autres gens se mettre en
travers de ce qu'on veut faire et
surtout continuer quelque chose qu'on
souhaite profondément on réussit
toujours à le faire bon voyez qu'ici à
chartre les femmes prennent toutes leur
place donc voilà prenez soin de vous à
très bientôt et puis n'oubliez pas des
fleurs des cœurs des couleurs du bonheur
même pas
[Musique]
peur